I think it's important for people to
know about what's happening in
Antarctica not only just that the
science that goes on down there but what
that science is actually trying to tell
us about the future of this planet most
of the research is really focusing on
climate change and trying to predict how
the continent has reacted in the past to
warmer climates and how that's going to
affect the planet in the future when you
first get down there the first breath
you take is you step off the plane it
really hits you it goes right down
through your lungs the cold air you can
feel it but after a couple of weeks and
actually working in that environment
your body does adjust slightly in the
colder temperatures aren't so bad as
long as you've got the appropriate
attire on to keep you warm the weather
is probably the biggest challenge for us
down there one minute it can be a
reasonably nice day and you've got good
visibility you can see where you're
going and what you're doing and within a
matter of minutes it can actually change
and you can't see a couple of feet in
front of you and you're stuck out there
without knowing where you are and where
you're where you tempt is aware your
nearest vehicle astir to retreat to to
to get some safety then it's a very
tough environment to conduct science and
to working down there every little thing
you do takes a lot longer and it's a lot
harder so changing the tire on a vehicle
which would normally be a five minute
job when your car at home will take you
an hour to two hours because of the
condition as you work in and petrol
sun's probably harder than perpetual
night to do or weather because to get
routines and patterns into your life you
can be awake at two o'clock in the
morning and it's like a nice cool warm
summer's day so you end up going for a
walk and suddenly we are routines going
away whereas winter it's actually a
little bit easier to get into a normal
daily routine